sesame street moving on from the
metaverse to the traditional boob tube
sesame street streaming through the good
old tv is is trying to
convince your kid trying to market to
your kid
the kovid vaccine does rosita
oh oh no
this is from my covenant vaccine my
mommy and my puppy took me to get it
this morning
oh rosita that's great getting the coba
vaccine is a great way to stay healthy
see my mommy and my puppy said that it
will help keep me my friends my
neighbors my abuela all healthy
your parents are absolutely right you
know coveted vaccines are now available
for children
five years and older and the more people
who get them the better we're going to
be able to help stop the spread of covid
and keep everyone healthy
this is sick this is really really sick
and i think a lot of people do not
appreciate how sick it is
because i think what a lot of people see
is
yeah
the libs are pushing the vaccine and so
they're doing it through any means they
can they're doing it on tv they're doing
it in the news they're doing it through
influencers they're just going to try to
sell it right okay
sure i get that
but sesame street is a show that is
almost exclusively watched by children
maybe a parent happens to be sitting in
the room but it's a show for kids
are are kids now supposed to be making
their own medical decisions is that
what's going on
i don't
last i checked it's not up to
five-year-olds to make their own medical
decisions it's up to their parents
right shouldn't you be marketing this on
parents shows you know cnn for instance
shouldn't sanjay gupta is over there
shouldn't cnn be saying hey parents
here's why you need to get your kids
vaccinated no because
the these people know that parents some
parents are going to say no actually my
kids don't really face a great risk from
the coronavirus and this drug is pretty
experimental and you know there have
been side effects some of which have
been deadly and documented by the fda
and cdc so no i'm we're just not going
to do that we're going to wait a little
bit and the libs really want to get
everyone to take the fauchiachi and so
they're going to go directly to the kids
as if the kids are a higher authority
here
kids are idiots by the way right that's
the kind of the definition of a kid is
they don't know anything that's why they
have to go to school and be educated
isn't that the reason they're watching
sesame street in the first place because
they don't know anything so they need to
learn their abcs but now you're telling
me a kid is so sophisticated that he
knows better how to make these complex
medical decisions than his own parents
that's what they do though
it gets to something else we talked
about on on friday which is the
different ways you can look at politics
for the left and for libertarians the
basic unit of politics is the individual
everything is about the atomized
individual for conservatives the basic
unit of politics is the family
those are very different ways of viewing
the world okay
but the the hyper focus on the
individual means of course they got to
market it to kids and by the way of
course kids can choose if they want to
get a transgender surgery which
increasingly many of them are and
they're going to come to regret it but
that's their individual choice and the
family has no role here because the
family is the actual
impediment to the left taking control
right the family is the actual
structural obstacle
that that obstinate little
atom of society
that
will stop the left from totally taking
control thanks for watching that vid man
i'm glad you liked that if you want all
of the cool vids
and clips and episodes full-length
episodes ring that bell subscribe here
on youtube sometimes our overlords on
this platform
don't like to send the notifications so
if you want to be sure to get the full
uncensored show all the time head on
over to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play subscribe to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]